نحن سننتصر تقول العباره على لوحه
الاعلانات هذه وسط تلابيب هي جزء من الحرب
الاعلاميه التي تخوضها اسرائيل بموازاه
حربها في غزه وللحرب الاعلاميه مايسترو
يدير
ايقاعها تحت المستشفيات توجد اسلحتهم
ومقراتهم وهذا النفق هو اثبات على ذلك وقد
بنى سرديه الحرب على ثلاث اسس التاكيد
الدائم على ان اسرائيل هي الضحيه وانها
تخوض حربا
عادله اننا نخوض حربا عادله لا مثيل لها
حرب بداها العدو باختياره لم يشهدها
العالم الغربي منذ عقود الترويج
الانتصارات حتى وان كانت بعيده عن الحقيقه
او مخرجه بطريقه
سيئه اذا ما تبعتموني من وراء الجهاز
فترون ما الذي عثرت عليه قواتنا حقيبه
لحماس والتستر على ايه معلومه من شانها
الاضرار بنفسيه الاسرائيليين وبمعني
الجيش ولتحقيق ذلك يحضر مقص الرقيب
العسكري في وضع جمله من المحددات
والمحظورات على الاعلام منذ بدايه العمليه
البريه مارس الجيش الاسرائيلي التعتيم على
اعداد جنوده الجرحى لكن صحيفه يديعوت
احرونوت نشرت تقريرا صعق الاسرائيليين اذ
كشف عن ان عدد جرحى الجيش وصل الى 5000
لكن وبعد ساعات ازيل الرقم من العنوان
الرئيسي وظهر مكانه الرقم 2000 وهو عدد
الجنود المعاقين من بين العدد الاجمالي
للجرحى
انذاك تضمنت قائمه الرقيب العسكري محددات
صارمه اشتملت على امور عسكريه وسياسيه على
حد
[موسيقى]
سواء
يرافق الرقيب العسكري اسرائيل منذ تاسيسها
فهو كاتم اسرارها وحارس امن معلوماتها
والمتر على جرائمها الممتده من مجازر
النكبه وما بعدها الرقيب الذي يتبع لشعبه
الاستخبارات العسكريه طال يقصه كل نواحي
الحياه لم يكن بالامكان البوح بعلاقات
اسرائيل الدوليه ولا باستقدام يهود العالم
وظلت موارد اسرائيل الصناعيه والتجاريه
ومشروعها النووي طيه السريه تراجع دور
الرقيب العسكري في بدايه تسعينيات القرن
الماضي مع تطور الاعلامي وظهور الانترنت
لكنه احتفظ بسطوته لا سما في اوقات الحرب
والازمات
[موسيقى]
ا
ه بم كسسو اسك لقد ساد ما يشبه الاجماع
والتوافق بين الرقابه والجيش وبين
الصحفيين على نحو تطوعي بان اسرائيل دوله
فريده من نوعها ومحاصر ويجب عدم نشر بعض
الامور مثل النووي الاسرائيلي او موافقه
الصحف على عدم النشر عن مجزره كفر قاسم
وقد اجتهدوا لاخفاء امور لا علاقه لها
بالجيش الصحافه تجندت في خدمه السرديه
الصهيونيه في السنوات الاولى لقيام الدوله
وما زالت تفعل ذلك حتى
يومنا ومع ذلك لم يكن التعتيم الاعلامي
الذي حاول الرقيب العسكري فرضه ممكنا في
ضوء ما تنشره المقاومه ومنصات التواصل
الاجتماعي من مقاطع فيديو احرجت واجبرت
الجيش الاسرائيلي على الاعتراف بما كان
يفضل التستر
عليها
هكذا اضطر الجيش الاسرائيلي للاعتراف
بخسائر بعد ساعات واحيانا بعد ايام من
استهداف قواته ومواقعه العسكريه من قبل
المقاومه في اول ايام العمليه البريه
اعلنت المقاومه تمكنها من دحر قوه عسكريه
اسرائيليه شمال قطاع غزه تكتم الجيش على
الخبر لمده اسبوعين قبل ان يجبر على
الاعتراف بالواقعه اثر تحقيق صحفي لديت
احرونوت في الثامن من كانون اول ديسمبر
الماضي اعلنت المقاومه مقتل الاسير ساهر
باروخ في عمليه كوماندوس فاشله للجيش
الاسرائيلي لتحريره بعد شهر تقريبا اعترف
الجيش بمقتل الاسير لكنه لم يتحمل
المسؤوليه عن ذلك وهكذا ارغمت اسرائيل على
الاعتراف ايضا بمقتل الاسيرين ايتاي سبرسي
ويوسي شرعبي بعد تلميح المقاومه لمقتله في
غارات جويه
اسرائيليه
نحن نعرف اننا قصفنا مواقع قريبه من مكان
احتجازهما ونحقق في الحادث واسبابه ونفحص
الصور التي نشرتها حماس في الايام الاخيره
التقى ممثلون عن الجيش بعائلتي ايتاي
والمخطوف الاخر وعبروا عن قلقهم لمصيره
عقب ما توفر لدينا من
معلومات القرار بحجب الصور مشترك والرقابه
تحضر اظهار لحظه القوات لانها نقطه ضعف
وتجري متابعتها امنيا وذلك يندرج ضمن امن
المعلومات الصحافه لا تنشر هذه المقاطع
لانه لا احد يريد ان يرى ابنه وهو يقتل
برصاصه في الراس انه بالتاكيد امر يتعلق
بعدم المساس
بالمعنويات كل هو في
الخمس حجم الاعلام الاسرائيلي عن مشاهديه
النصف الاخر للقصه ولم يظهر شيئا عن اوضاع
الفلسطينيين وقد بدا اداؤه شعبويا منحصرا
في ارضاء دافع الانتقام لدى المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بعد احداث السابع من اكتوبر
وهكذا تراوحت التغطيه الاعلاميه للحرب في
غزه بين تعتيم وتعم ولعل السعي وراء صوره
نصر هو ما يفسر جزء من سلوك الاعلام
الاسرائيلي فالاعلام بحاجه للحكومه لانتاج
الدراما والحكومه بحاجه للاعلام لانتاج
السرديه ليسك رم الجزيره تلي
ابيب